انا الى تطورت حربي روسي على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلانات السلطات الموليه لروسيا انها حقق
التقدما في الجزء الشرقي من مدينه اوغندا
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت المنطقه 9 مرات
بنحو 40 قذيفه كما استهدفت اربعه احياء
سكنيه الى جانب قصر
هيئه الطوارئ الاوكرانيا
ما اسفر عن مقتل مسنه واصابه ثلاثه اشخاص
وبثت وسائل الاعلاميه صورا لعمليات
الانقاذ في المبنى المكون من اربعه طوابق
وفي خرسانه قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه بريس لاف ان القوات الروسيه نفلت
ليله الماضيه سلسله غارات على المدينه
استخدمت فيها الذخيره الحارقه المحرمه
دوليا وفق تعبيرها ومن جهتها قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
كسفت قصفها خلال الساعات الماضيه على
مقاطعه خيرسون وزا بروجيا جنوب البلاد
وشنت غارات الجويه
كما اكلت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه وانظمتها
الصاروخيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه اضافه
الى محطه ايرادار